who does who does which more do women
lie about their body counts more often
than men lie about their jobs
women have jobs to lie about oh come on
can we speak on the fact that some men
are making things up no men make more
than women maybe the men you deal with
most of them I'm talking about
personally as a whole like
generalization like as men sometimes
they do have like you know like you
would say like paid not good working
paying jobs where I was in the council
with I don't know 50 000 more than women
yeah for that men do that because they
need to hold a status like in in a lot
of men's minds they meant to be the home
bringer right but my point is like who
lies about which more lies man what's
your body pounds what's your body count
okay forget that would you tell somebody
that you're just meeting or just
beginning today your body count I've
never lied to
um a boyfriend about it good like I I
just I feel like you should be honest
like the guy was like approaching and he
was kind of like never tell no random
guy never he said but like people scare
tonight like maybe he's your boyfriend
but you've been seen to have a couple
times
no man if he's gonna be you tell him but
he won't become your man unless you tell
him your body count not as you just no
no no no so okay okay so listen if I'm
dating you we're dating for six months
seven eight yeah okay and you ask me no
first of all there's another energy that
we do you see a lot of times of men we
don't have to ask because we can feel
the energy you know you know you can
feel the energy right A lot of times
when the girls had a lot of bodies they
come off a lot of trauma and it and it
comes out in the way they interact with
men you can feel it the room can feel it
the energy is so when we feel this we
know so we already know it's not gonna
be a long-term thing but then there's
other ones you can't necessarily and
you're like you're gonna give the girl
the one opportunity and I said I want to
feel like Kanye this the reason I say I
want to feel like corn is because when
Kanye married Kim he knew egg listen he
knew exactly what he was getting into
this is why I don't if you cry if he's
crying now you're crying what are you
crying for bro you know what he's doing
yeah so that means that he could not
step into a room and he did not know
nothing about about her so no one can
come and embarrass her a lot what a lot
of girls do is they like a guy and then
they don't want to tell the full truth
so they start the relationship built
upon a lie but the thing about lies is
you know
okay some women a lot of women lie about
the body counts due to the fact that
they don't want to be seen as what men
do as well no okay so why why is it
whenever men make a statement about
women we have to say [ __ ] no we don't
even need to no okay no I'm saying but
we do like so it's just you know it's
true what I mean is it's equal okay so
equally we do the same thing okay so I
don't think like yeah if anything
equally sometimes if anything men will
light up about their body count so so
yeah that's my plan so the thing about
it is yeah women control access to sex
men control access to relationships so
I'm full of a beautiful panel of guests
right I'm sure any one of you guys will
not have problem getting men to sleep
with and if you say you you want your
capping because I can just know that
already right because you're all
beautiful women right but I don't have I
won't be able to have as much sex as you
will be able to have all you have to do
is literally say to a guy you can go on
social media now say to God yeah well
there you go right do you know what I
have to do to no come on after putting
that work in that Finance right all I
gotta do is walk outside yeah
well that's why they say women get what
they want and men get what okay so so if
we deal with that yeah that means you
are having sex whenever you want with
whoever you want versus I'm having sex
whenever I can get whoever give it to me
completely different thing right so if
we look at that then well women's body
count can be but imagine please yeah so
going back to your point about you said
about the body count thing right so
someone that I used today he said to me
that it only matters to him as long as I
haven't got with his friends what do you
think about that that's wait can I give
you a quick just um I asked guys this
question on my show all the time would
you rather have a girl that has five
bodies but you know two three of them or
a girl with Tony but a girl with 20 but
you don't know any of them and they all
say 20 buddies yeah yeah they all say 20
and I don't want to anybody
because loyalty well it's just more like
guys don't want to be embarrassed like
the biggest thing they want to be in
that to own it well it's just like it's
kind of embarrassing for a guy to walk
into a room and know that three of his
friends hit or like exactly yeah so it's
embarrassing so you have to remember the
body count doesn't matter in a lot of
situations so sex is invasive I don't
think I don't think body counts the only
thing but but
um but it matters and that's that's the
thing like if you go from if you're a
virgin and there's different studies
that I'll give slightly different
numbers but I'm just going to use them
this one just as an example
um if you slept with if you're a virgin
on your wedding night you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage drops down to
25 percent if you've slept with more
than five most guys would pray for five
nowadays
and and there's some studies that say as
a virgin at 60 70 I know people will
come for me on that but but the the
point is still the same you're more
likely to have happy marriage if you're
a virgin then if you're then if you
slept with more than five it's like five
to seven seems to be when you're ruined
as a woman statistically is that because
you don't know any better due to
experience yeah yeah partially yeah no
it's because basically like like the
guys that are the No No the guys that
are the best most girls can't lock down
because how did they get to be the best
they have a lot of girls
and if they're good and bad like how
many girls you think are calling them
and so like that's why the the
equivalent like that's why I say like
they women swipe right five percent of
the time and they hate men because
they're all sleeping with the same one
because it's again 100 of women want 20
of men and sometimes some people argue
it's five percent of men like what
percent if you want a guy that's over
six foot what percent I need you to
cough out of the microwave sorry
um like what percent of men do you think
are over six foot fifteen percent but
don't you think that's creepy because as
females in general get older of course
we're going to have more experiences so
why is it you have to have this
completely pure image like we're not a
little girl but why of course the
problem is is that you're not satisfied
and the older you get you can't keep
those guys anymore so by 30 you've lost
50 of the options that you had at 20. so
on dating apps like they'll say this
many guys swiped right on you it goes
down by 50 at 30.
and and so the guy that the guy so the
guy the not really um the guy because
guys will filter you out based on age
because they just think the women their
age like they don't want to deal with
they don't want like kids they don't
want an ex-husband they don't want that
stuff and so it's like then the guy at
20 that you know or 25 whatever it was
um that that you keep thinking about you
can't keep
I think it's just double standards on
this one you're right it is a double
standard but it goes back in biology you
can't change the things that men want
like like the reason that a low body
count matters is because
um historically they had to ensure
paternity so if a girl was sleeping
around like um paternity tests are new
like that's a new phenomenon that that
wasn't there throughout history so
um they didn't want to pass on resources
to a kid that wasn't theirs the same way
like most women want a guy they're
height or taller would any of you date a
guy five inches shorter than you
okay possible but but not common right
the most most women like if they dated a
guy shorter than them it was one to two
inches it wasn't significant and so
that's because historically you needed a
guy to protect you and you can't get rid
of that like but you can't get rid of
your biology yeah but po look how easy
it is for gold to say I won't date a guy
that's
um five inches smaller than me but if I
say I don't want a date a girl that's
fat people start getting mad but you're
entitled to your own no no no but
generally people be like oh you're fat
shaming but I'll be but you can change
your weight you cannot change your
height like you're born that way so if
you shame a man for his height what can
he do but if we say to lose some weight
you can actually go and do something so
I just think like a lot of times women's
you can earn more money but you can't
reduce your body count
[Applause]
yeah you can't she can't change that
yeah what's happened has happened but
you can earn more money so the same
argument that you're saying that a woman
can lose weight a man can't grow taller
it's the same thing there's certain
things that are restricted but were
still judged upon no but based on the
biology of what we want now but your
body count is your choice yeah so like
that that you had a choice in men don't
have a choice in the height he's born
he's not necessarily true though okay so
we're not talking about great okay okay
just in terms of that okay I need you to
if you're gonna talk I need you to talk
into the mic because it's just okay
we're just saying with it that body
count like essay like what if you okay
we're talking about the rule not the
exception yeah so whenever so if that
happens we're never talking about that
just you know we know about those
scenarios we know about it but but like
when we speak about this we're talking
about consent consent yeah so we can
take essay out of that because we're not
speaking about that we we understand
that right because if we do then we'll
just keep going everywhere we're talking
about consenting if we're talking about
a consenting woman that chooses to sleep
with 20 men cool versus a man who is
born that way and cannot change it you
chose to open up your legs to 20 men he
cannot choose his height so it's not the
same
I feel like maybe some women maybe some
women maybe a little bit yeah sorry
sorry guys I feel like maybe some women
may be a little bit bitter or upset
because obviously
um men will advertise men will advertise
one thing but want something different
would give attention to one thing but
want something different like I've
witnessed personally like guys putting
up loads of captions every day or every
other day about loyalty hoes hoes
loyalty homes
but they like I know of certain people
they are attracted
which they may know or not know to the
hose for one night stands not for a
while I'm not saying to wife back there
but like the attention they're giving
this home yes
the effort they're giving this hoe the
attention they're giving this hoe the
entitlement yes it's for the pumps I
understand Pearl
um yes it's for the
for the one hit whatever but as wifey me
watching that Pursuit and then watching
him pursue me
I'm just gonna be like do you know what
you're doing no your wifey he's all so
women have to understand women have to
understand the difference between men
wanting sex with you versus wanting
actual commitment with you yeah I
understand that's the difference but
sometimes it looks I know I know I know
but it's not the same trust me because
the outcome is no it's been put out the
pursuant might be but the outcome is
different so when men all chase after
these girls yeah versus you you're like
oh you meant you said you don't like her
but why is he liking the pictures why is
he doing these sorts of things that's
because he wants one thing what you need
to do is you need to separate yourself
from those goals so we get a lot of good
girls that chase the top 20 or bad boys
right so when you're a good girl what
actually happens is when you chase these
boys you don't actually become a good
girl anymore you just become the same as
one of these hoes because what you're
doing is you're putting yourself step by
step next to holes and you're saying oh
why won't he pick me or why is he
treating that these are holes they're
always going to be holes and this is
what they're gonna do and good girls
have always been on the other side and
holes have always been on that side but
the problem is good girls are now
looking at holes and be like why are
they get why the holes getting love they
are hoes that's it we staying strong
it's like it's a meeting strategy for
men it's like men are men are like
they're biologically predispositioned to
like screw as many girls as possible so
like they're it's crazy if you talk to
like men about their attraction floor
and like what girls they find like there
will be girls that like I do not think
like a guy would find attractive but
like out of their attraction floor if
you got one thing if you got one body
part that's good they're into it like
it's just yeah that's true as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible